i like being batman
the villains are people that are doing
wrong but a hero to those that need to
be protected our culture
so you know they were a lot of fun to me
making examples you notice i taped all
that [ __ ] you saw it because i captured
it yeah i just want y'all to see that
you know that's how i treat them sucker
[ __ ]
and y'all could treat them the same way
too
that's why i showed it and captured it i
want you to see the truth
they make you believe that there's
something they're not and that you need
them and you don't and behind closed
doors certain people kiss ass and
certain people make them kiss the ring
i make them kiss the ring or that make
them bend the knee i'll break their back
till they bend the knee
and i think that that is something that
can be applied just self-awareness of
who you are and what our culture
represents yeah we're the jewel of the
universe
and the only way to control the jewels
that make the jewel think that the jewel
is not the jew
i'm not going for that dumb [ __ ] i know
i'm the jewel i shine
and my culture shines
i think that that has kind of been the
blueprint of the music industry right
making artists think
that they need the label culture make us
fight each other
and [ __ ] protect our oppressor like
they [ __ ] ought to plug
it's a good program
you know
kudos to the enemy
but once we're aware of it why keep
letting them winning that way knowing
that it's just a mental thing physically
we kick ass and mentally too we just
have to know it
and it takes it takes like i feel like
finally he takes doing it i feel like
finally there's like a new generation of
artists that no the kids just listening
that's what i was investing in the first
place yeah i was like these old
[ __ ] do not listen they're just
stubborn
they're complacent they just want to
survive
get the next advance check
survive never recoup and be depressed
and then be like what the [ __ ] i don't
consider that living yeah i feel like
they're this
finally this
era of artists at least it seems like a
young a lot of these younger kids well
you see our revolutionaries understand
that
yeah
they do
but we do have to stop glorifying us
killing each other
because that's just them celebrating
that's a w every time
one of us gets hurt and it starts doing
it to each other every time it's us
doing it to each other
and then the suicide mission the bad
food we keep putting in our body
like how you gonna trust your pressure
oppressor to feed you
he's pissing on your food bro
i would never let my enemy feed me that
doesn't make sense
it's not logical i never let the person
that's knocking me down give me food
religion or anything i'm not listening
to nothing you saying because it's only
to control me
i'm aware of that
i think we all are but everybody's [ __ ]
that's the problem
fear is implemented it's a program to
stop us from making our dreams come true
and most of the things we're scared of
never happened
until you think about it so much that
you manifested
you know when you're sitting around
thinking about [ __ ] you're scared of
that means you're not doing nothing
about it because when you're doing [ __ ]
you ain't thinking about the past you're
thinking about what's in front of you
you know so if you got time to reflect
that's too much time you should be
working
too much time reflecting the suckers
[ __ ] to me
that's licking your wounds
i'd rather fight and that's what i want
to be famous for fighting i don't want
to be famous for rapping
i want to be famous for acting
i want to be famous for kicking some
[ __ ] ass to those that deserve it and
helping people that i love
and that's what i'm gonna go down in
history for
an ass kicker